Well, this is probably the biggest question.
How many miles do I train for a 5K?
Anyone from eight to 80 ask me this question.
And unfortunately, it varies for everybody.
If you're running your very first 5K of your life,...
...you might only be running five or six miles a week...
...and building up to that point.
The elite competitive 5K runners might train 100 to 140 miles per week.
So the question is, really, how much can your body handle without breaking down?
And that means for people who are beginners but have done a 5K before,...
...probably 10 to 20 miles a week.
For those who are a bit more of an intermediate,...
...you're looking at 20 to 30 miles a week.
And local studs and elites are probably moving to 40 to 50 range.
But really, you need to just sort of play with it and see what your body can handle...
...and build from there.
So the lesson is, whatever your body can handle is best for you.